[موسيقى]
لا اعتقد انهم سيطبقون العقيده العسكريه
الغربيه بالكامل اعتقد انهم سيجرون عليها
التعديلات كما يفعل كل الجيش
[موسيقى]
انهم يستخدموا الاسلحه الغربيه
ماثر على عقيدتهم العسكريه يبدو انهم
يستخدمون اطلاق النار الدقيق والمدفعيه
والصواريخ الدقيقه بخلاف استخدام الروس
اطلاقا نيران لتغطيه مناطق شاسعه وهذا احد
اكبر الفوارق بين الطرفين ولكنني اعتقد
انك اليه ما يحاول استخدام المدفعيه
لتسهيل او خلق الفرص لمدرعاتهم ومشاهدهم
هذا ما يبدو عليه الارض
[موسيقى]
اكثر مشاهديكم على درايه بحرب عام
1973 بين مصر واسرائيل التي غالبا منشار
اليها على انها حرب صواريخ بسبب استخدام
الصواريخ المحموله الموجهه المضاده
للدبابات التي يسميها الغرب وهي عباره عن
صاروخ مضاد للدبابات بحجم حقيبه الملابس
كبيره جدا في عام
1973 وهذه الحرب
حيث تستخدم فيها الصواريخ الموجهه
للدبابات والصواريخ ارض جو المحموله
[موسيقى]